resolvamos esta desigualdad para p
tenemos el valor absoluto de p menos 12
4 es menor que 14 entonces hagamos esto
un paso a la vez lo primero que queremos
hacer es deshacernos de ese valor
absoluto y para hacer esto lo que
podemos hacer es es es deshacernos de
este 4 positivo entonces restamos 4 de
ambos lados menos 4 y menos 4 así que
del lado izquierdo tenemos 4 menos 4 eso
es igual a 0 se cancela solamente nos
queda el valor absoluto de menos 12 y
del lado derecho tenemos 14 menos 4
veces igual a 10 entonces 10 y nos queda
el signo de menor así que tenemos el
valor absoluto de p menos 12 es menor
que 10 y pensemos en esto un poco porque
si yo te digo que el valor absoluto de
de x es menor que 10 eso qué significa
significa que la distancia de x al cero
debe ser menor que 10 entonces si yo
tengo una recta numérica y aquí tengo
aquí tengo al cero sólo podemos llegar a
10 de hecho de hecho no
diez días muy lejos debe ser siempre
menor que diez por eso tenemos el signo
de menor estricto que 10 entonces esto
debe ser menor que 10 luego podemos
avanzar por la izquierda hasta llegar aa
menos 10 y aún así no podemos incluir al
día es cierto entonces el valor absoluto
de x menor estricto que 10 podemos
incluir el valor absoluto de 9 o al
valor absoluto de 9.999 99 pero no no al
entonces otra manera de escribir esta
desigualdad con valor absoluto es decir
que x x debe ser mayor que menos 10
entonces x debe ser mayor que menos 10 y
x debe ser menor que 10 o podemos
escribir que x está entre menos 10 y 10
entonces menos 10
menor que x y x es menor que 10
es otra manera de escribir lo mismo
esencialmente lo que estás diciendo aquí
es que x debe estar entre menos 10 y 10
pero no puede ser menos 10 o 10 ahora ya
podemos usar la misma lógica en el
problema original tenemos el valor
absoluto de p menos 12 y podemos
escribir la de la siguiente manera
entonces tenemos menos 10 es menor que p
menos 12 p - 12 y p menos 12 es menor
que 10 entonces podemos aislar a la p
que quede en medio y para esto vamos a
sumar a las tres secciones 12 para
eliminar ese 12 que nos estorba entonces
sumamos 12 aquí 12 acá sumamos 12 acá y
nos queda menos 10 más 12 que es
entonces esto es igual es igual a 2
entonces 2 es menor que aquí se cancelan
los dos se nos queda simplemente p&p es
menor que 10 más 12 es igual a 22
entonces tenemos que que es mayor que 2
y menor que 22 ahora qué te parece si lo
dibujamos en una recta numérica entonces
nuestro conjunto solución se mirará algo
así aquí tenemos el 2 acá está el 22 por
acá puede estar el 0 entonces p es mayor
que 2 no es mayor o igual es mayor
estricto que 2 entonces ponemos un
círculo abierto y es menor que 22
entonces menor que 22 no es menor o
igual entonces ponemos un círculo
abierto porque es menor estricto y será
todo lo que está entre el 2 y el 22 de
hecho lo podemos verificar intentémoslo
con algún valor que pueda funcionar por
ejemplo el 12 el 12 está entre 2 y 22
entonces de igual a 12 tenemos el valor
absoluto de 12 menos 12 más 4 debe ser
menor 14 aquí tenemos cero más 4 debe
ser menor de 14 y en efecto 4 es menor
que 14 así que funciona perfectamente
pero por ejemplo el cero no debe
funcionar porque nuestra nuestro
conjunto solución cierto entonces vamos
a intentarlo con el cero
veamos tenemos el valor absoluto de 0 12
+ 4 no debe ser menor de 14 veamos vamos
a llegar a alguna contradicción tenemos
valor absoluto de menos 12 4 menor que
14 y entonces 12 más 4 menor de 14
tenemos 16 es menor 14 contradicción
cierto eso el cero no va a funcionar
porque no está en nuestro conjunto
solución mientras que todo lo que esté
en nuestro conjunto solución si
funcionará